I'm Joy Behar and you've got Easter traditions.
When I was a kid, it was a major holiday.
The whole family, the Italian family, would gather around my Aunt Rosa's table...
...and stuffed themselves into oblivion with all the food she would cook.
Well, there was an Easter pie that was made.
My Aunt Rose, she would make, it's called the pizza rustica.
And it's this big Italian pie and it consists of, basically, cholesterol.
You have tons of cheese, you have about a dozen eggs in there,...
...heavy cream, salami, and she would bake this thing.
We would eat it on Good Friday and Easter Sunday we would rise from the dead.
Egg hunting was left for American types.
We were Italian Americans and we had a meatball hunt.
We didn't do an egg hunt.
Now I like an egg hunt...
...because I don't have any eggs of my own anymore.
My grandchild has just been born, his name is Luca.